this is a feeling of whether or not
humanity will receive this early on
there we go doing our button check here
it's making sure with everything all set
and ready to go use the as well peg
don't with the muster one though ah
must've as well God dang it disrupts
there a few bells and it's gonna play
what he wants that's true
alright here we go heading into Game one
between kinetic clash it o matic let's
get it rocking in the ruin of the stage
you know random stages beautiful stuff
alright it's gonna block the set things
often enough idiot
dunk from kinetic class is gonna walk
his way in to say you know what I'm not
afraid of you I'm just gonna walk in
great dealing with that mix up there
picks it up Wow well that is very
advantageous my idea that situation all
of GI launchers for however out of the
ranges IV in the jump back just gonna
lay it up with the greatest of etho
floater coming based off his balance on
you gotta love it oh just let down a
little bit but not today
you know a classic keep this kick though
check out these heels I'm wearing these
yeah I love went with players helps it
slowly Soul Calibur globalism
literally just trying to do anything for
the list to get that last whether it be
dunk of two rounds up so slick so fast
connect clash hey Casey I'd appreciate
it if you let me complete a sentence
before you complete it the round thank
you do what you do above that is a quick
two rounds if I ever seen it before but
automatic not to be outdone fighting
back breakdancing clearly as well
invented that what what year the game
take place first time I saw it can exist
sit back in and decide step into the
lethal kinetic clash making this a bunch
of a one player game as it is practice
the first time you boot it up may play
ride spinners it wolf addict says wait a
minute now this is when you put the
practice AIO a human and we fight back I
don't want to play our game let me get
on the board a little bit going on but
dang right into the back ago excellent I
love my kinetic class
yeah good opportunity there to negate
the to a placebo they double down on
that man I said it's not like the first
one got blocked it just got negated
because it didn't exist through so
charge first so you know for his own
data he needs to figure out if it worked
and it did this atop the auto GI is
gonna get the launch no follow-up from
uber said looking for a tech situation
finds its way to freedom activates so
charging was the door gave one the
kinetic watch definitely started fight
back to the final round but clinic clash
looking really solid and love the how
they both feel like a lot of fake it's a
lot of tricks on each other right it's
like okay who can get the better rate is
what's gonna have it happen in the
situation right so akin in a clash had
those reads I also said himself I would
just double down a moose so it's like
try to block it once have a second time
yeah I like the
any any opportunity we get to take a
look at the place he gave me the empty
seat nod where it's like I know I want
that but I could have done better and
you have to really keep your eyes
because those are the people who get
better as a tournament goes on it's like
the workhorses you keep feeding them and
then eventually it's like wow we really
can't do anything about this but instead
poof addict
gonna try something different I spun
it's all good here we go true smack
flapping back gonna get those muscle
buster this time when they're first you
don't succeed okay put this off like
twin swords dance like the - and right -
try to paint something out but there's a
very good range nice all right I like it
pause stop gonna take a look at Ivy she
is you know easy on the eyes as well
remembered what he was here for Oh get
the leaflet on a way Rudd get mad damage
for the football is follow up right now
not even using any meter to get that
much damage oh love it who's still
working on a perfect tear uh a bit
ambitious there the shot way too close
easy sidestep for PC but again yeah they
keep a lot of uh getting a lot of
mileage out of that beyblade Oh careful
hello - aroused to zero and it wouldn't
be the LCQ without a response right we
get the more recognizable the more
acclimated the player you know you
better expect these close fights at
Kohl's Browns gonna deny that to a [ __ ]
an emphatic has found the answer for KC
in the mid-range and a completely
different game than we saw in the first
one and this time trying to keep the
perfect one hit will do it and you still
perfect to make sure because there it is
seven golden letters on the screen o
matic with an answer if we haven't seen
one so far
right yeah good oh you like to add your
you know your eaves and ours and swish
them around I just have to you know make
sure we actually have like three used
added it to perfect by the way
yeah either way no matter how you spell
it it's the same in the fighting game
language around the world and we're
putting that on the board one two one
two just big good thought it was gonna
be free clean sweep right we saw Casey
take the first two rounds in about 30
seconds total do you have one and uh you
know we've just going back and that's
something as a competitive player that
you need to be able to do right dust off
the last game go back in your bag and
say hey look I know he cooked me for
three rounds but that's just one game
but he needs to win exact tying it up
and setting the neutral resetting the
school setting combining everything look
first I might shake up some stage today
so gonna be pretty interested to see
what happens here a lot of ring out
potential swings both characters big win
it how about a sidestep lethal hit don't
throw things at me sir my daddy shoes
guns all the time I've been ready for
this here we go check yourself right
back in though Oh muscle buster gonna
get the wall off this no are we too far
away nobody gets it as well it's too far
away all that matters is the angle and
the red health oh my goodness okay see
we refusing to watch his legs oh yeah
who sniffed that one now easily ain't
going back to the same man I love that I
love that bringing in that heat right
now you know one of the oldest things
this isn't life if it ain't broke don't
fix it
show a you that a prime example going
through that swinging low time and time
again keys
you need to figure it out there it is
yes the block gets the whiff 600 and you
heard the screams screams of fear
company from the crowd hoping that it
was not a counter here what if it's Big
Top trouble with stairs gonna do the
Buster Buster what in trouble KC's gonna
spit the poor to keep free the auto fee
are beautiful
all right fishing for a little bit there
Oh - a-plus jr. tonight she gives us a
little show right there beautiful stuff
with the lights down low okay
launch PowerPoint is off of the fossil
Buster having none of it
go for three of them things couples that
get away from me so charge that hit like
nigh don't want nothing but you when
she's done right oh that was beautiful
stayed on the ground and let the bay
play go right over another point is from
KC sniffing it out lockable setup boost
a get position around incredible job and
kinetic class right now but let's see if
I can bring it back loads a meter to
utilize your two bars of butter oh my
goodness a get up out of that suffering
that's right yes well fighting for
things giving it everything else I do
many but instead it is I've been trying
to use this browser this is so much time
spent rolling around to avoid
potentially waking up in to regale
situation Oh both whipping so much here
good either punished on that beauty the
wolf but to how much reason is left in
the tank move cannot afford to lose this
round it's a guess here we go and that
is going to beat it Casey closing the
door and bouncing back himself as my fan
in the front roll just laid back Tillis
yeah the Christmas trees have to put it
up as Casey fools born in the same size
that's right that's right beautiful
beautiful job by both players Wow like
really brought that heat though man like
he he that spicy stuff he had a lot of
really great
ducks really solid gameplay in general
but you know what kinetic lash brought
that too yeah it seems like he just kind
of ran out of gas there everything when
it's a hyper drive in that second
did not go down - oh and he said you
know what this is what's working and I'm
gonna go ahead and just spam this
circuit move you're gonna meet me here
this is what you're doing on the ground
of Kasey was like right oh look
flex a little bicep the right one twice
straight because you think everybody got
it right
you know you a kid if you were a
cheating kid and you like real stuff
wanna anything and he pull out of the
test like that little button in there
yep it's tight so every time we turned
around looked at everything I don't know
that's that beautiful sitting on he took
a look at his notes oh yeah just kicking
right now sit on this cloud and save 15%
by using the promo code as well gasps oh
that's okay he's saving too many people
think it should go off double wide until
November 30 here use the code as well
and get a dxracer guys